calé sur un truc assez intéressant c'est
le dell xps 13 plus c'est un autre
acteur qui est pas encore arrivé parce
que trouverait au génial c'est qu'il ya
un design car parti-pris t'il vraiment
différent tout ça c'est une tête d'ubs à
tout ça voilà tout ça c'est votre pavé
tactile c'est complètement dingue et là
vous avez des petits raccourcis des
touches fonctions mais qui sont en fait
super bien intégré est un super beau
design je trouve que là dessus d'elle a
vraiment bien bossé alors ces tout
petits formats c'est du très ça arrivera
au printemps mais je voulais vous
montrer avant conteste d'ici un bon mois
et demi parce que c'est monsieur elle
est superbe elle est à mon avis elle va
vraiment faire un carton plein